has russia achieved any of its war
objectives in ukraine it's three months
since vladimir putin launched his
so-called special operation
is the continued conflict complicating
efforts to find a diplomatic solution
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom three months into
russia's so-called special military
operation in ukraine the invasion
appears to be turning into a drawn-out
war thousands have been killed millions
are homeless many communities are in
ruins leaders from both sides say
they're far from any talk of a ceasefire
ukraine's president is warning of a
bloodbath as russian forces intensify
operations in the east and the south
velodimerzelinski demanded even tougher
western sanctions to send a message to
the kremlin that brute force will not
prevail germany's energy minister says
the european union is closing in on an
agreement for an embargo on russian oil
and a russian diplomat has resigned in
protest boris bondarov says he's ashamed
of what he calls the war-mongering lies
and hatred by russia's foreign ministry
zayn basravi reports from ukraine's
capital kiev
the war in ukraine has not gone as
expected
keeve was meant to fall to russian
invaders in a matter of days
three months after missiles shells and
paratroopers began landing in and around
the capital ukraine
is putting the spoils of war on display
morale and anger at russia are now so
high ukrainians say the only acceptable
victory will be taking everything back
occupied territories in the east even
crimea
yes i believe the return of our
territories is possible and i think we
should not stop i believe there should
not be any negotiations about returning
to the same borders we had before the
start of this war
no
we should get our cities and crimea back
this is our sovereign country and we
should defend it
the truth is on our side we are
defending our land we really want and
hope for this to happen
yes ukraine need weapons and
our our army
will will do everything and we will win
i'm not i'm sure
there was less optimism when all-out war
came to ukraine on february 24th
russian president vladimir putin's
so-called special military operation
was the biggest assault on a european
state since world war
ii
the u.n estimates at least 14 million
people have been displaced so far at
least six million to neighboring
countries
when missiles hit a ukrainian army base
in yavariv near the border with nato
member poland it was the furthest
russian attack in the west of the
country
the siege of mario pole so violent it
wiped the city off the map leaving
little doubt as to how far russia was
willing to go to achieve its aims
unable to penetrate ukrainian defenses
around the capital russia's withdrawal
from bucha revealed civilian killings
that ukraine described as war crimes
the invasion did change the map but not
perhaps as putin had hoped
finland and sweden applying to join nato
stands to more than double the
alliance's border with russia
just weeks ago independence square was
under lockdown and covered in snow
now people line up to buy stamps
commemorating a moment in the early days
of the war
when ukraine in no uncertain terms told
russia to leave its territory
i hope that it's a good sign that
we can win
in this war and we can survive
so for me it's a sign that we have a
chance for a good future
things look very different in the
ukrainian capital today diplomatic
missions are reopening people are
returning and ukrainians seem far more
optimistic albeit cautiously than they
did at the beginning of this war
but the war is not over russian forces
are escalating offensives in ukraine's
east re-mobilizing forces to
battlefields in the south
all indications are conflict with russia
is the new normal
and as long as russia controls the skies
over their country
nowhere in ukraine is completely safe
zayn gosvi
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in la viv in western ukraine
dimitro shilgam european program
director at the international
renaissance foundation
in london domitila sagramoso senior
lecturer in security and development in
the department of war studies at king's
college london
and in moscow dmitry babich political
analyst at the inosmi internet media
project a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining the program
today dimitro let me start with you is
the war essentially at a stalemate now
has this basically become a war of
attrition at this stage
uh it is an active phase it is a war of
attrition but at the same time
it is not like a bliss creek it's
already a third month
actually end of the third month
uh and there is no
end of the war inside so it's like uh
it's more like world war
one maybe in terms of space now what we
are having in uh
in the eastern ukraine where the major
fighting is going on
dmitry has russia achieved any of its
objectives in ukraine and and where do
things stand militarily right now from
the russian perspective
well
i can give you a perspective which is
shared by many russians but which here i
also read for example in june you know
the german magazine where uh oscar
waffenton very well known british gave
his assessment of the situation
and it was very popular with russia
he thinks that there were actually three
stages the first stage was the nato
expansion which was one of their reasons
for the war the second was putin's
decision uh to invade uh in february
this year which was uh the second stage
and now we have the united states
getting involved more and more sending a
huge amount of weapons you know uh
allocating for 40 billion dollars on the
aid for ukraine which which shows that
the united states doesn't want it to be
another afghanistan they wanted to be an
active war in which russia would lose uh
as for russia's goals and their
achievements
part of them were achieved
because uh you know crimea was debunked
now water is coming to crimea from the
ukrainian territory
uh basically herzog which is an
important city in the south was taken
mario was taken
fighting
however russians have not achieved one
of their main goals and that was to to
move the front line away from donetsk
which is a huge uh megapolis and which
continues to be bombarded
uh by the ukrainian artillery so part of
the aims were achieved part of them were
not and of course there was no regime
changing if which was probably one of
the initial goals that's why the russian
troops tried to move towards kiev from
the russian territory they retreated now
so
this story over regime change uh swift
regime change uh we can say that this is
it
dr matilda how much is the continued
conflict complicating efforts to try and
find a diplomatic solution
well i think at the moment there isn't
really a very
strong diplomatic initiative i mean
there were a few proposals that were
brought forward for example by the
italian government
uh but they also envisaged for example
that there would be a retreat of russian
forces from the areas that they have
occupied in ukraine and i think that is
probably not going to happen
so i think that at the moment uh there
is a much higher chance that the fight
will continue with great intensity
and only either if one one of the two
sides decides that they want to sort of
give up
uh and and plea for some kind of
diplomatic solution or both sides after
quite some time feel that they
need to reach some kind of that they
have reached a sort of hurting stalemate
and they decide to sort of reach some
kind of ceasefire agreement but i really
don't think that we are there now i
think both sides seem very determined to
continue with a fight
and and i think because as was explained
the objectives were not achieved russia
has not been able to defeat the
ukrainian armed forces which is one of
the main objectives uh on the other hand
uh the ukrainians uh are still uh you
know fighting hard to make sure that
they dislodge the russian occupiers from
the areas of the east uh and the south
so i think this this is going to be a
war that's going to take uh quite some
time still um and i think that any
diplomatic efforts at the moment are not
going to see any results uh so that i'm
not very optimistic on that front but
it's also understandable uh dimitro
where does ukrainian public opinion
stand when it comes to the the
possibility of some kind of a potential
diplomatic solution and also in in the
early stages of of the conflict it was
being reported that that perhaps
president zielinski might be amenable to
giving up some territory or or possibly
to agree to neutrality for ukraine
if that were to happen would the public
support that
no no but it's definitely
it's definitely a moot in ukraine
that we cannot
we can't compromise our territorial
integrity and we can't compromise our
sovereignty
there's so much human losses
losses of human life there's so much
losses so
i mean there's
so many atrocities have become known
which what russians are committing on
the temporary occupied areas of ukraine
so it is absolutely non-negotiable not
non-negotiable
to compromise with russians and to agree
on some sort of
i don't know partitioning of ukraine or
something like this or give up some land
or something like this absolutely not
and it's definitely
now
support for
no appetite for seeking some sort of
uh ceasefire agreement which
i mean like what has been done in 2014
2015
when
basically there was a agreement
so-called means agreement
uh when there was a ceasefire and
russians basically
haven't fully uh implemented the
ceasefire and they haven't withdraw
withdrawn their forces from the
temporary occupied areas
and then later they now just basically
used the temporary occupied crimea and
temporary occupied donbass
area to launch a larger scale attack on
ukraine
so that's why we understand that what we
need is really to have
such an agreement where
uh precondition would be first for
russians to withdraw their forces and to
accept
that they should
restore ukrainians territorial integrity
and sovereignty
it's clear now that russians are not are
not there
so that's why i agree i mean russians
are not
uh
this now and they're not ready to
withdraw their forces so that's why
basically the war continues because
russians started this invasion and they
want to continue this invasion they want
to put their terms on ukraine which is
unacceptable ukraine is
basically
uh doing itself defense
we are defending our country
and uh there is no compromise on our
territorial integrity or sovereignty
dmitry from from your vantage point uh
you know obviously diplomatic efforts
have failed thus far do you think that
they could pick up again at some point
um and do you think that there is the
potential to have president putin and
president zielinski meet at some point
perhaps face to face
well as to the meeting face to face
we heard a very
belligerent statement from president
zielinski
just recently a few hours ago
uh
which means
uh basically uh you know zillianski said
that he would only meet with putin uh no
one else and that he will only talk
about the total withdrawal of russian
troops uh that means that this meeting
is not going to take place any time in
the near future because the positions of
the sides are too different
uh i would say that zelensky changed his
position many times
during the first days uh of the russian
onslaught on kiev we remember how
zielanski said that neutral status could
be acceptable and could be negotiated
and then the ukrainian delegation needs
to basically again talked about
uh non-membership and nato and mutual
status uh as possible solutions but then
the ukrainians just withdrew their
uh
you know their propos well they they
change their position in fact so
this was the reason why negotiations did
not restart i think
uh as for the positions of the two sides
i respect metro's opinion i think he has
his right on it but
i would uh uh kind of advise uh our
viewers to read the minsk agreements you
know they were signed in 2015 uh at the
moment when ukrainian army was basically
losing against the militia in donetsk
lugansk and the the main points and
these agreements was uh you know one of
the points was about giving the special
constitutional status to the
russian-speaking regions in the in the
east that was not done
the second was about lifting the
blockade you know mr poroshenko then
president of ukraine imposed a total
blockade on donald's
there was no food for them you know no
water no electricity no pensions so uh
basically russia accuses ukraine
of uh not have it fulfilled the minsk
agreements uh and the word russia if you
look at the minsk agreements was not
mentioned there once
the agreement said that all foreign
troops should be removed from ukraine
but that is not only russian troops we
know that the the british were building
up basically their base near chukov in
the south of ukraine they said it was a
training center uh but no one would
check this training center so it was
basically a mini base american warships
were uh in uh in the black sea
all the time you know uh so the reason
why pujan decided to act the way he did
a lot of people in russia do not support
it openly the reason why he acted the
way he did was because he would not in
his opinion allow
more bases of nato countries on the
territory of ukraine and he was afraid
that the situation would finally slip
out of control as more and more
ukrainian fighters were trained
by american and british instructors more
and more weapons were flooded in ukraine
especially in the two months
before february 24th when uh putin made
his uh announcement and look i mean
russia cannot dislodge the ukrainian
army from donbass uh
so if ukrainian army attacked uh when
russian army was still in russia if they
attacked they would of course they would
have crushed the demetrius
demetria they would have won the war i'm
sorry to interrupt you we're starting to
run out of time let me pick up on one of
the points you were making in just a
moment with another question um
domitilla so germany is saying that the
european union is likely going to agree
to an embargo on russian oil imports
within days um what kind of impact do
you think that's that's going to have is
that something that would that would
automatically weaken russia
uh i'm of the view that the sanctions
are weakening very much the the russian
economy uh and that is part of the
objective uh it's uh not really regime
change as it's often mentioned it's
actually really to weaken the the sort
of the capacity of the
russian economy to sustain the military
conflict so i think it's it's very
important to continue with this uh
sanctions even though uh there isn't
maybe an immediate change of the actions
of russia on the ground and i think it
will have an impact definitely because
russia is relying very much on selling
oil and gas
to western markets and to europe in
particular as far as gas is concerned
and also all so and the prices are much
higher so when russia has to uh sell its
energy products to other consumers in
the east uh or um
globally they tend to buy now at lower
prices so russia certainly is losing out
and i mean it's also going to be
a cost maybe for the global energy
market so of course there is a cost to
be uh to be paid as a result of this uh
sanctions uh but uh from the european
perspective i think there is increasing
agreement that this is uh the right
approach that we can't be fighting you
know russia and ukraine and at the same
time become uh sort of one of the main
purchases of uh of its energy products
so i think that this consensus at the
level of the european union is
increasingly uh being reached it will
take a bit of time but i think that uh
that's probably where we are heading uh
dimitro um the u.s the eu they have
imposed lots of sanctions against russia
thus far um president zilinski and other
ukrainian officials have said that that
more sanctions need to be imposed
from your perspective have the sanctions
that have been imposed thus far
actually had their intended effect have
they acted as a deterrent
you see i mean
just first of all to react to what
dmitry just said uh
because it's fake news what he said
about uh nato's basis in ukraine on
ukraine's territory there was no
permanent nato bases anywhere in ukraine
and generally speaking
uh ukraine until 2014
was a very pacifist country with
military virtually non-existent with
no public support for nato membership at
all
since 2014 when russia attacked ukraine
aggressively absolutely ungrounded
took part of its territory crimea and
part of donbass
of course ukraine had to build up its
military and of course ukraine had to
seek
support and the cooperation with other
first of all with nato which is able to
provide military support
uh and actually if we look from that
perspective it is actually russian
leadership it is putin who is putting uh
ukraine moving
forcing ukraine to move to nato because
nato seeks protection from russia by the
way the same way is now sweden and and
finland which realized that they need to
have protection from russian aggression
dmitry you were talking about nato a few
moments ago dimitro was just talking
about nato that obviously plays a role
in all this i mean president putin did
not want ukraine to become a member of
nato but now you have finland and sweden
that have applied to join nato and there
are many analysts who suggest that nato
is in a stronger position now than it
was three months ago did did president
putin actually foresee that finland and
sweden might apply to to join nato if if
this course of action were taken in
ukraine well first of all i would like
to uh
make uh some uh you know corrections uh
precisions on what i just said because
metro said that i said there were nato
bases on the tetro ukraine no
uh
there were bases uh training centers
organized by the united states and
britain uh formerly they were not nato
bases but de facto
ukraine was becoming a nato member
because there were american
instructors
and there were foreign specialists
foreign of ukraine everywhere since uh
2014 and even before that as for your
question about finland and sweden i mean
look at the news in the western media
there were dozens of military exercises
uh in which phoenix and swedish troops
participated together with nato troops
and they were all against russia so
russia of course is not happy about
finland
and sweden not
no longer be neutral countries
but i think in the in the end this is
first of all a blow to the image of
europe you know
europe was a peaceful continent with
many neutral countries now there is just
one left switzerland that even
switzerland is not neutral completely
you know dimitri i'm sorry i'm so sorry
to interrupt you again but we're almost
out of time and i just want to ask
domatilla one one last question here
tell me we have about 30 seconds left is
there any member of the international
community that you think can offer an
off-ramp to president putin that he
would deem acceptable
i think in a way that's not an
adequate question because i think that
putin should not be offered a ramp to
save his face i think it's very
important to send a clear message uh
by the international community to russia
and other members that these kind of
military aggressions to neighboring
countries are completely unacceptable
and that these sort of situations are
not going to be accepted globally in the
future they have destabilized the
european continent they have created a
lot of distress human casualties and
brutality inside ukraine there's serious
problems globally in terms of supplies
of food and fertilizers for example
the prices of energy also skyrocketed
their problems which we haven't really
discussed around the blockage of the
export of products of ukraine
through the black sea and this is
creating uh
as i said a rise in in food pro
products so all these elements which now
have serious global implications and now
there are discussions among uh the
united kingdom and lithuania as to
whether do something to de-block uh the
black sea and the access of ukraine so
that it can export its products because
it's really having serious global
repercussions to the global economy at a
time when the economy was already trying
very slowly to recover from the impact
of covet so i think that at the moment
the emphasis should be on trying to um
help ukraine uh to really reduce
russia's military presence in ukraine as
much as possible and see if some kind of
agreement can be reached that uh results
in russia's withdrawal at the moment the
only actor that could maybe put pressure
on russia is of course china but china
seems not at the moment ready to sort of
um put pressure on on russia to reach
some kind of agreement
on on retreat and instead is is playing
a sort of a a a game of uh sort of
support in terms of political
understanding of the position of russia
and uh and in a way sort of providing
you know the the markets that russia
needs for the export of many of its
energy products so i really don't see a
possibility of any sort of immediate uh
negotiated solution and let alone one
that would allow putin to sort of save
his face and a sort of a run off thank
you all right well we have run out of
times we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests dimitro shulga domitila
sagramoso and dimitri babic
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim joham and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you